[Music]
[Music]
the last glacial period on earth began
to fade around
11 000 years ago the kilometers thick
ice sheets that covered much of the
earth started to recede
and the earth entered into the holocene
the current geological epoch
but the once mighty glaciers did not
disappear entirely
in the extremes of our earth the north
and south poles
are the remnants of the last ice age
these frozen tundras easily reach
temperatures as low as negative 40
degrees celsius
and sometimes dip far below that
darkness envelops them for entire months
at a time
they are places that seem wholly
inhospitable to any living creature
temperatures are so low that hypothermia
can quickly set in
and ice itself can form inside the body
it's crystal shredding tissue
ripping cells apart but for millions of
years
evolution has forged remarkable
adaptations across the animal kingdom
to ward off the icy grip of death it's
the reason arctic animals have
specialized heat generating tissue
and the reason polar bears are invisible
in infrared vision
it's what shaped our circulatory system
and
why so many traits appear in cold
weather animals that appear
nowhere else in the evolutionary tree
when the ice starts to take hold
what hidden strategies compounds and
dynamic physiologies of animals that
live in these frozen tundras allow them
to survive
sub-zero temperatures are a problem for
all living things
because all living things are largely
made up of water and when water freezes
it expands and becomes sharp this is
frostbite a death sentence for any cells
it forms inside
cells that make up vital organs also
have optimum operating temperatures
and when core body temperature falls the
heart
nervous system and other organs can't
work normally
this hypothermic state can lead to
complete organ failure
and eventually to death and so to
survive an extremely cold climate
there are two things an animal can do
prevent heat from leaving the body
or create more the animal kingdom is
made up of endotherms and ectotherms
the fancy words for warm-blooded and
cold-blooded animals
it's a misconception that cold-blooded
animals don't create heat like
warm-blooded animals
they do they just can't retain it and
regulate it like the endotherms can
endotherms primarily birds and mammals
use metabolic heat to maintain a stable
internal temperature
often one warmer than their environment
when it gets particularly cold outside
endotherms can increase metabolic heat
production
in what's called thermogenesis one of
these methods is something we're all
familiar with on a very cold day
shivering skeletal muscles tighten and
relax
in rapid succession to produce extra
heat and keep the body warmer
but some animals especially hibernating
ones
have an extra heat generating power
using a specialized fat tissue called
brown fat
or brown adipose tissue animals can
create
heat without moving a muscle this is
called non-shivering thermogenesis
brown fat works very differently from
white fat which is the fat we're more
familiar with
white fat stores extra energy and is
what builds up in obesity
but brown fat breaks down sugar and
white fat to create
heat burning up calories instead of
storing them
brown fat generates 300 times more heat
than any other tissue in the body
it's loaded with much more mitochondria
than white fat
which also act differently than most
mitochondria
rather than creating atp the energy
carrying molecule
like most mitochondria do these
mitochondria
are designed to turn fuel molecules
directly into heat
small mammalian hibernators use brown
fat more effectively than
any other creature before hibernation
they undergo a large increase in brown
fat
not to get through hibernation itself
but rather to help them get out of it
hibernation involves going into a state
of decreased physiological activity
usually paired with a reduced body
temperature and metabolic
rate this decreased state of activity is
called hypothermic torpor
it enables animals to survive periods of
reduced food availability
like in harsh frozen winters but when
more favorable conditions arise
these animals need to be able to raise
their body temperature to return to the
world in search of food
and arousal from this state is no
trivial task
it takes about one hour and involves
violent shaking and muscle contractions
while brown fat works to burn off energy
stores to rapidly warm the body
but creating heat like this comes at a
great cost energetically speaking
as much as 75 of the total energy
expended during a torp or bout
is used just for arousal a huge amount
of calories needs to be consumed for
any amount of thermogenesis and this is
why sometimes
it's better to not just create heat but
to keep it from escaping
in the first place
the temperature of water in the arctic
ocean hovers around negative 1.8 degrees
celsius
it can be at a below freezing
temperature due to its salt content
since water conducts heat 25 times more
effectively than air
water this cold is capable of sapping
away large amounts of body heat
but what should be an inhospitable place
for mammals is instead
full of them and surprisingly marine
mammals have
no special increased heat generating
mechanisms
no increased metabolism to keep them
warm instead
they have an adaptation found nowhere
else in the animal kingdom
blubber blubber is a specialized layer
of fat that lives under the skin
and is anatomically and biochemically
adapted to be an efficient thermal
insulator
like other adipose tissue blubber is
composed of numerous fat cells called
adipocytes
which are filled with lipids aka fat
blubber can be up to 93
lipid with very little water content and
because lipids have a low thermal
conductivity
it doesn't transfer heat as well as
other tissues like muscle or skin
this makes it an excellent insulator
blubber covers the entire body of
animals such as seals
whales and walruses except for their
fins flippers and flukes
animals with the thickest blubber like
right whales can have blubber as much as
50 centimeters thick
other animals like polar bears have up
to 11 centimeters of fat surrounding
them to help keep them warm in the water
but when on land a different adaptation
exists to keep them warm
their heavy fur coat close to their body
is fluffy white fur
which traps dry warm air next to the
skin
and all around that is their outer coat
which is made up of hollow transparent
hair called guard hairs
and because of these hairs polar bears
are almost completely invisible in
infrared vision
infrared radiation is a part of the
electromagnetic spectrum that we can't
see
but can feel as heat warm bodies emit
this radiation
which is what infrared cameras can pick
up on polar bear guard hairs absorb this
radiation more effectively than almost
any animal hanging on to the warmth
rather than letting it be lost to the
cold environment
and because nearly all of the infrared
radiation is absorbed it won't show up
on
infrared cameras this makes aerial
surveys and population counts
challenging for researchers
their white color camouflages them and
only their nose eyes and breath
appear in the infrared spectrum a polar
bear's specialized fur
is a very effective way to trap heat
against the body
but some animals aren't lucky enough to
have such an effective coat
most notably us this is why a more
hidden adaptation courses
through the body of many endotherms
the body's surface is the main site for
heat exchange with the environment
especially in those of us with no fur as
warm blood flows to the outside of our
body towards the skin
heat radiates away and is lost and so
when the temperature outside plummets
the flow of blood to the skin
has to be controlled to keep the body's
core temperature at a safe level
and while hidden beneath the surface
you've probably felt this effect
once the body senses cold it constricts
the thin web of capillaries in your
extremities
starting off with your fingers and toes
then moving farther up your arms and
legs
this shrinking of the blood vessels is
called vasoconstriction
and its goal is to keep warm blood
around the vital organs
keeping them safe even if it means
risking frostbite in the extremities
many endotherms have this
vasoconstriction ability for when the
weather gets cold
but to keep their extremities from being
damaged some animals have counter
current heat exchange systems that allow
heat to be transferred from blood
vessels containing warmer blood
to those containing cooler blood animals
like wolves use this extensively in
their legs and feet to keep them from
freezing
blood leaves the wolves core at a warm
body temperature and travels towards the
feet
while the blood returning from the feet
has been cooled down from the
environment
as the cold blood runs up the leg from
the foot and passes by the warm arteries
it picks up most of the heat from the
arteries from conduction
and conversely the blood flowing down
from the body is cooled
this means that less heat will be lost
from the feet due to the now
reduced temperature difference between
the blood and the surroundings
and that the blood moving back into the
body's core has been warmed
helping maintain the body's core heat
humans can do this to some extent
but not as well as many of the arctic
endotherms
instead some people particularly people
whose ancestors lived in arctic climates
take the vasoconstriction of the blood
vessels one step
further after some time in the cold
certain people's constricted capillaries
will suddenly dilate sending a rush of
warm blood into the now freezing
extremities
briefly warming them before constricting
again this prevents the extremities from
being severely damaged by frostbite
while still ensuring that the vital
organs stay warm
the cycle of constriction and dilation
is called the hunter's response
people who live in cold environments or
people whose ancestors did
have this automatic response inuit
hunters for example
can raise the temperature of the skin in
their hands from almost freezing
to 10 degrees celsius in a few minutes
cold
tolerant animals like those found in the
polar extremes of the earth
are at constant war with freezing
temperatures
behavioral strategies physiological
processes
and anatomical features all work
together to keep the cold
out of their bodies but what if avoiding
freezing wasn't the only option
what if instead you just let the ice
take you over
for us and most animals this would mean
certain death
but for some strange animals giving into
the cold entirely
is not only possible but advantageous
some animals even take it so far as to
freeze completely solid
their heart stops their brain activity
ceases
and yet come spring they completely
recover from what should have been
certain death in the next video we'll
explore how scientists have realized
that preventing freeze is not the only
way to survive the cold
and see how we humans are trying to
harness these powers for
ourselves behind every piece of research
every scientific story there is a human
one
much of the ecology and physiology
explored in this video was
only made possible by the people in the
field in these icy landscapes taking
measurements or observing animal
behavior
these human stories fascinate me as much
as the science ones
and this is why we decided to start a
podcast to explore just this
modulus hosted by me and brian from real
engineering
is a podcast about the people behind the
scientific stories we tell you here on
youtube
we will talk to the scientists who are
on the cutting edge of research
and the people who are affected by the
topics we discuss
from people who have spent months as
saturation divers at the bottom of the
ocean
to the people pioneering liquid battery
technology
to the people affected by the decision
to introduce genetically modified
mosquitoes in florida
this podcast will show the real-life
people behind these topics
and the real life impact these
scientific stories have
on the world the first episode of
modulus launched today on nebula
the streaming platform made by me and
several other educational youtube
content creators
it's the place to watch and listen to
our videos and podcasts ad
free along with original content that's
not available anywhere else
like real engineering's the logistics of
d-day series or tom scott's game show
money
we can take more risks on nebula where
we don't have to worry about the youtube
algorithm
there is so much original content there
with more being added all the time
and to make it even better nebula has
partnered with curiosity stream
the streaming platform with thousands of
high budget high quality documentaries
there are loads of documentaries about
ecology and animal behavior
like this one called polar bears it's a
beautiful
overview of polar bear biology with
stunning cinematography of the arctic
landscape
if you've hesitated before to get
curiosity stream and never quite pulled
the trigger
now is definitely the time to do it for
a limited time
curiosity stream is offering 41 off
their annual plans
making a yearly subscription just 11.79
that's less than a dollar per month so
by signing up
at curiositystream.com real science
you'll get a subscription to curiosity
stream and a subscription to nebula for
just
1179 for the entire year
signing up is also the best way to
support this channel and
all of your favorite educational content
creators
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
instagram twitter and patreon are below
you